♪ ♪
(echoing):
Deepak?
Mike?
Great.
Unbelievable.
Excuse me.
Excuse me,
I'm trapped in my own mind.
Could somebody help me
get out of here?
Hello? Hello?
♪ ♪
Ooh.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
-Oh...
-(moans, giggles)
(woman squealing)
(squealing turns to laughing)
-(gasps)
-You!
I'm the same age as you!
(cackling)
No. No.
(eerie choral music plays)
(groans)
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
No! No!
MALE VOICE:
I am you.
You are me.
You are teeth and hair.
You are a lie.
You are vile. You are evil.
-(eerie whispers)
-You are a liar.
-(wild grunting)
-You are... (indistinct)
You are a person
of flesh and blood.
-(wild grunting stops)
- You are not special.
-(echoing scream)
-You are not special.
You are not special.
-(echoing scream fades)
(eerie choral music plays)
♪ ♪
(eerie choral music
stops abruptly)
(sniffing, exhaling nearby)
(sniffing nearby)
(rapid panting, sniffing)
(panting and sniffing
accelerate)
You are born.
I'm born.
You are fired.
I'm fired.
You die.
I die.
(high-pitched squealing)
♪ ♪
OTHERS (in unison):
You are one of us.
We are all the same.
Who is the person you hate?
It is me.
Who are the ones you attack?
They are me.
Who are the ones you fear?
I fear myself.
We are all the same.
We're all the same.
I am not special.
I'm so, so sorry for who I am.